this is episode 16 of storycast 21 i'm
jane secker
on november the 26th 2008 10 islamic
terrorists sailed from pakistan into
mumbai india's largest city with a
population of more than 12 million and
began a highly coordinated attack that
would go on for four days
this is escape the taj mumbai
[Music]
i'm daniela federici
i'm a photographer and a director
originally from melbourne um i'm half
italian half australian
i'm separated so yeah so i've got one
child
well i've been to india many many times
so i'm very familiar with the crazy kind
of hectic
city of mumbai
my team and i were doing a tv series on
the last of the maharaja's
and we arrived there the 26th of
november 2008
[Music]
my name is ashish joshi i am a sky news
correspondent
i count mumbai
as almost
a second
home
it feels like everyone in india at some
point in their life must go to this city
it is known as the city of dreams
at night time we were coming in from the
airport and so it was kind of a lot of
traffic a lot of people on the street
there was a hot humid night
we were staying all the taj properties
throughout india
they were one of our sponsors for the tv
series was for ovation television
america and around the world actually
and the reason why we're going there
that night is to meet with the head of
the pr who'd flown in from delhi to meet
and greet us and just sort of send us on
our way
the taj hotel is in south mumbai it's
one of the most famous
buildings not just in mumbai or in india
but in the world it's a luxury five-star
hotel which
sits right on the arabian sea incredible
victorian grand facade
stunning building stunning architecture
instantly recognizable
by anyone who is familiar with india
and when i arrived it was um checking in
of all the silver nomads which is all
the couples that do their big retirement
trips there was a lot of australians and
brits in their sort of i'd say 60s
checking in at reception it was quite
packed the reception area because
everyone just arrived
they quickly dispersed across the city
striking targets right throughout mumbai
including a popular tourist cafe
hospital cinema marketplaces nobody
including daniela could have known that
already
a group of ten men terrorists from a
pakistani-based militant group
called lashkar-e-toiba were rampaging
through the city also in their gun sites
the city's
railway terminals they were armed with
guns and explosives and had just
attacked one of the city's main train
stations
and a cafe very close to the hotel
itself
now
they were bound for the taj
their aim was to kill as many people as
possible
so i sent the camera gear up with the
bellman
and paid him some cash and then i had to
fill out a form because i had the room
so i gave the indian girl at reception
my australian passport and i said look i
don't have time to fill out the form now
i'm running really late for a meeting
and she said oh yes the meeting's been
changed from the restaurant up to the
bar
as we were standing there
you could hear sort of the sound of
fireworks in the distance
and i just said to my cameraman i said
that's really peculiar you know it's
november it's not wedding season so
strange to have fireworks in india at
that time
and as we sort of moved away from the
reception and went towards a staircase
to go up to the bar on the first floor
they came into the reception area
we know the gunman entered the dodge
hotel
just after nine o'clock in the evening
people were falling to the floor people
were screaming people were hiding
and we kind of ran up the stairs and
from that point our sort of adrenaline
kicked in
we ran up through to the right into the
bar all my crew were waiting sitting at
a table having a drink
so i said look there's someone coming in
with guns we've got to do something so
basically just slam the doors closed and
we barricaded it with couches and the
furniture
and by the time they came around to
where we were we barricaded it quite
severely so they couldn't really get
through
and there were bullets flying around the
room but we were able to sort of hide
behind furniture in the bar and the
columns that were there
and we could hear them killing people
outside the door and they were throwing
them in the stairwell
very good evening let's bring you up to
date with the very latest from the city
of terror mumbai hit by a wave of
terrorist attacks the focus appears to
have been two luxury hotels the taj
palace and the trident obroy there was a
padded kind of
wall behind the bath and we realized it
was doors so we sort of plied it open
going from the bar into the second
ballroom was all of about
20 minutes as soon as they stopped
shooting us through the doors we just
jumped up and ran ran across
in the next room was a small ballroom
which had an indian wedding going on and
they had no idea what was going because
the music was so loud so they was
dancing we sort of grabbed them and said
hey guys you know this is serious so we
all went from that room into
a large corner ballroom and as we went
through we closed the doors behind us
and barricaded with the furniture the
room so they couldn't really get in
and there was another door going onto
the stairwell the staircase
and we barricaded that
family took the ice buckets from the
wedding and tried to break them through
the windows because the windows were all
locked and double glazed and because
they were double glazed you know
we didn't know at the time but it's
really about a small point of impact and
we were using these big ice buckets with
the boys were trying to smash through
all their mic wasn't breaking through
these windows so
basically we were stranded in that room
mumbai city is in lockdown
the tension turns whispers into rumors
how many more terrorists are hiding in
india's teaming millions
is a second wave i arrived on the 27th
of november
2008 and
that's about 24 hours after the first
initial
reports of the attack police and the
indian navy have searched to ship the mv
alpha which sailed to mumbai from the
pakistan port city of karachi once it
was moored off mumbai it's believed the
attackers used inflatable dinghies to
reach the shore just beside the gateway
of india and that's right next to the
taj palace hotel the group responsible
for the attack
is called
now that means soldiers of the pure
there are pakistani-based
militant organization who claim
to be fighting for the muslims
in indian administered kashmir
at the main train station young asian
gunman caught on camera sprayed waiting
commuters with automatic weapons
many people died on the station's
forecourt and platforms the gunman
reloaded three times
these
terrorists
landed their boats maybe five to ten
minutes away in one of these small
fishing villages dotted around the targe
there were reports coming in of people
who had been shot dead and injured
possibly dozens by this stage
throughout the day gunfire and
explosions have crackled around the
buildings at the center of what is
basically a battle
the situation
was changing all the time
the the wide
spread attack
that had taken place at key targets
across the city had now centralized it
was focused on the dodge
we can see outside that it's
chaotic scenes outside i mean there's
cars everywhere blocking trying to block
the entrance
of the hotel the police response was
slow
chaotic
and the police officers who went
to the scene
weren't very well armed they had
antiquated
rifles and i don't think there was an
overarching plan the fighting or the
shooting is still going on
we were in the main ballroom trying to
get out obviously we couldn't get
through these windows so you know on our
blackberries and iphones we could sort
of track what was going on and we soon
realized that
it wasn't just one crazy person because
we didn't know what was going on it was
just some person revenge of a you know
romantic revenge or whatever it was we
realized you know that there was attacks
in the
subway or the train station and the
leopold cafe and the other things and
reading about it we realized it was an
organized terrorist attack
it became apparent very early on that
this was going to be extremely difficult
and complex
operation there were hundreds of people
trapped inside
if you can imagine a huge
luxury hotel
story after story
long row after row
room after room
and in each of those rooms they could
have either been terrorists or residents
so mounting any sort of rescue operation
even with a blueprint of the hotel was
going to be extremely difficult
what was really bizarre was the indians
police didn't call in their special
service the indian police didn't have
guns and when they did try and go in at
the very beginning they were just
massacred by the machine guns
we even like downloaded a architectural
plan of the building and sent it to the
embassies and saying we're in this room
can someone come with a ladder and just
get us out
and of course no one could come because
you know they were shooting off the off
the top of the building and they were
you know no one could get in or out of
the building from where we were at least
because we're 30 feet up in the ballroom
level
and then they worked out about five
people in the building
[Music]
the terrorists had knocked out the
electricity
we could hear explosions
grenades going off inside the hotel
there were fires
and
it was pitch black and thick acrid smoke
bellowing from the hotel
chaos and confusion for a second night
as this mumbai terror attack continues
la toriba would have known that if you
attack mumbai you will get headlines and
to have a running siege for four or five
days with no other news being reported
around the world that's exactly the sort
of attention this terrorist group craves
and no one was coming to get us it was
really quite bizarre
all the indians were calling friends and
i said look guys we've got to just text
we don't want them to know we're here
and how many are here and what's going
on said please just go to text everyone
just went silent
[Music]
but we could hear people being
um
killed playing for their lives and then
you know being shot and the bodies were
being thrown over the stairwell and they
were piling up down below we got all
that from all the iphones and stuff like
that
and apparently you know they were
calling rooms and saying it's safe to go
out and they were killing people as they
came out so we got all the news reports
but we we also you know got the reports
that um the fire was sort of
wrapping around the building
india has one of the biggest
24-hour
television news networks
in the world
there were hundreds
and hundreds
of
tv satellite trucks
all along the front of the hotel
and
these reporters were all in their
stand-up positions reporting on what was
happening behind them they were being
fired on as well so every so often you'd
hear a shot everyone would die for cover
the police were really very worried
about the
rolling news coverage because everything
that was happening was being transmitted
live
and it was pretty obvious at the time
that whoever was talking to these
terrorists inside and guiding them could
see what was happening
people were absolutely
petrified they were in this hotel
waiting for the security services
to come and get them but
if you're in that position
what do you do do you take a chance do
you make a dash
for safety if you run through the hotel
there's glass on the floor there's smoke
it's pitch black you can hear the
explosions you don't know who the
terrorists are and on top of all of this
you are absolutely terrified
it's unimaginable horror
[Music]
about halfway through when it was all
going off and the fire was everywhere
the whole building kind of moved a bit
because they were trying to wire the
tower and explode the tower of the dome
and i i noticed the chandelier in that
room was um clinking with the all the
vibrations in the building and i said to
someone like guys let's move the indian
stuff because they were lying on the
floor sleeping through it all because
the reality is they weren't really that
worried because they were after the
westerners so we said to the guys come
and get up we've got to move you and
they are really pissed off obviously but
literally within a minute or two the big
dime exploded into those explosion and
the whole chandelier came crashing down
alex can you update us we've heard some
noise
yeah they they seem to be uh firing uh
grenades down the side of the street not
actually
that would seem to be returning gunfire
then we thought someone would come
through the windows and say that's we
really thought that would happen but
then after two days and fires above us
and smoke coming we realized no one was
coming for us so that was it well there
was a lot of smoke around the front the
front arch
but it's uh it was just one of those
waiting games mike mike crew were a lot
of australians they were making jokes
just to try and make light of the
situation but it was looking pretty
bleak and it got to a point where the
smoke was completely over
us and coming down and we were probably
going to die of smoke association before
we died of burning from the fire
the smoke was around us you know and i
had to text my ex-husband and my son who
was two and a half then
um you know saying that basically
mommy's not gonna make it home i'm sorry
i love you guys but i'm not gonna make
it again it's aimed all at the second
floor
doesn't seem to be particularly directed
inside the room we all hugged each other
and laid down to die holding hands in a
circle in my group and literally a
couple of minutes later
they'd thrown a grenade off the ceiling
to hit someone below and it ricocheted
or something happened but anyway out to
the windows smashed
so that we all jumped up
and the smoke started to clear and we
basically just smashed through the
windows and took the long curtains that
are from the you know 16 or 18 foot
curtains to the ballroom floor tied them
together in nautical knots because a lot
of us are sailors and got half the
people down that way
we're seeing some pictures now
from mumbai of people coming down some
steps of civilians clearly foreigners as
well being escorted
down some steps in by the time we got
half the wedding and people down um they
brought a ladder over and then some of
us went down at the end and within the
past few minutes a truckload of another
20 soldiers have arrived just in the
last few minutes not quite sure the
siege was
eventually broken by
a group of
extremely brave
commanders highly
skilled needed
specialists who had been flown in
from delhi the evidence as related to
the militants is the language that has
been intercepted by
these were the black cat commanders
equivalent to
the sas
protests have replaced gunfire and
grenades on the streets of mumbai today
the city's residents previously
paralyzed by fear blamed their
government for lapses in security that
allowed a gang of militants to terrorize
we managed to leave two days later
i lived in new york but we had a house
in australia sydney and bona beach and i
just didn't really want to travel
anywhere and now the tales of the
survivors are being told and as these
tales are told people will listen and
people will be eight
in australia
a very strange thing happened where my
agent from new york said look there's an
ad agency called sacs agency that do all
the high-end luxury hotels and they just
got their taj campaign relaunch you know
to do that and they'd love you to do it
and i said to my agent did they know i
was a hostage they know i was there and
my agent said no i said wow what have
strange thing out of every photographer
on the planet they choose me
and going back a few days before we went
back i must say i started to have panic
attacks so i did a decompression thing
where i had to learn how to take the
nastiest moments of the night
in full technicolor you turn it black
and white
you shrink it down and you put it in
imaginary box and you close the lid and
you put it away in a drawer and that
kind of stops you triggering um panic
attacks that come from
post-traumatic stress
so i took the entire crew that was
suffering and they were there from that
there was one scene that we wrote where
it was in the stairwell which is the
horrific you know where they were piling
up the bodies
to see the staff celebrating the
staircase with balloons and streamers
and doing a hurrah we photographed this
scenario of them on the stairs and it
was quite beautiful
a lot of the trauma and the the
emotional damage kind of was cleared
through that sort of cathartic moment of
going back and photographing the
campaign and feeling safe in those
places again
and i think the whole situation with the
terrorists they were young boys they
were being paged to kill people they
were arguing they didn't often want to
shoot people
but i still to this day don't blame the
kids holding the guns i blame the people
behind me
[Music]
[Music]
over the four days from november the
26th to november the 29th 2008 at least
175 people including nine terrorists
died in the mumbai attacks it was
subsequently discovered that the attack
was directed remotely from pakistan
for more on this podcast log on to sky
news dot com forward slash storycast 21.
escape the taj monbai was recorded by
tom gillespie writing production and
sound design was by rob mulhern
storycast 21 will return in november
2021 with its final installment of
episodes
[Music]
[Music]
you